Mary an older woman knowing what we know
about pregnancy and infertility in older
women
so would you get into a relationship
with a woman that was over the age of 35
that wanted kids and knowing this is a
possibility no
what about you oh Sam likes and Mike no
okay tell me why China I feel like you
got thoughts
um because
because geriatric pregnancy starts when
is the start age is it 30 29 30 you
start to lose it I think geriatric
starts at 35 but you've lost most of it
yeah so you lose mostly X by 30 Joey
actually pregnant she starts at 35 I
would like to have three to five kids I
don't have any kids so far so I come
from a big family so um yeah I would
obviously need to be a woman that could
that could compare him yeah and you know
what it is like I'm just I'm just real
man like like I have to put this out
there because there seems to be some
thing that men don't understand as you
get older because I'm in my 30s and that
like things just get so much better so
it's like my girls and my girls in their
20s and that and I guess I get women all
the times in the 20s that have no
problems that would move to me so this
is something where so what tends to
happen is a lot of women in their 30s
because they they spent their 20s
chasing off the Chad and Tyrone and and
getting one through getting higher body
counts getting trauma getting kids or
whatever you're not so by the time they
get to their 30s and then they wake up
and then like the girl said before she
was having a panic attack or whatever
they start looking that the guys that
they didn't look at but the thing is now
like these types of guys were not
actually looking at you and then if
you're out in a club store and you're in
the 30s there's a new set of women that
are out now from their 20s right and and
the guys you didn't look at when you
were chasing off Chad and Tyrone and now
the guys that you're chasing after but
they haven't access to all types of
women so a lot of times you will get
women that get in their feelings to
start saying stuff about oh man and they
thought he's trying to date younger
women or it's because they want to
control them and do all this no the
reason they're saying that is because
it's competition now and they're out in
the same exact same place and they're
going after the same group of men and so
they want to make it fair but life isn't
fair when we was younger and I was 18
and 20s and that and they were dating
all the older mans and they were popping
bottles and jumping in the cars like we
had to we had to take the pain it wasn't
nice they had the sparklers the uncles
were doing their thing but it's not as
cool as cool as a western they're the
sparklers and that they were jumping in
the whips you know we was watching what
was going on sparklers you know you know
the bottles yeah you know but we went to
very different high schools no like one
was out so so so we've seen all of that
so now now we're the uncles and we're
living alive and some people are are not
happy but the difference is a lot of the
the younger women they have seen what
you women haven't seen in these men that
you've missed and now you're directly in
competition with them so what I always
put out to people is you need to use
your your prime time from 18 to 28
you've had 10 years literally outside
like you've had good guys you've had
guys in your DMs guys stacking shelves
guys studying guys that you've aired but
you're chosen to go after the top 20 of
guys that have access to multiple women
guys that can have one baby with one
woman and then actually get you to have
babies with them again so my thing is
this is this you know things get so good
and we don't take baby mums around here
bro listen yeah hey let me say something
yeah because I come in really late yeah
listen listen listen let me say one
thing yeah I do not have sympathy for
you chicks yeah when you get old you hit
the wall and then you start complaining
oh where's all the good men gone brav
you had the Good Men they're in your
friend zone in your best yes bro yeah
when you're tasting China Tyrone like my
boy said yeah yeah you're smashing guys
like China and King riches bro it's your
fault bro yeah and then like at the end
of the day bro it's on you bro you're
adult bro you know what I'm saying you
talk you chasing bad boys and and drug
dealers and rappers and YouTubers and
all of these kind of people but at the
end of the day you only got yourself to
blame fam are you both single then what
are you both
not even though no no no no I'm active
I'm active I'll say I'm active yeah are
you single yeah why because I want to be
right now oh okay interesting so anyway
as I was saying yeah boom like and then
you get old and then boom like your your
options have dried up and you've dried
up as well that's it bro you know I'm
saying and don't blame no one in it
don't cry in it because when you was
winning you didn't care about nothing
nothing
you didn't care about the guys in your
friend zone you didn't care about the
guys that want to treat you right or
nothing bro because every man here has
had the situation where you like to go
and you was willing to give that girl
the world and everything and it was it
wasn't even a hypersexual situation it
you wanted to go on picnics hold hands
Skip and all of that rough yeah she
cheated on them with you
he changed the whole time but listen at
the end of the day you hurt feelings in
it so when the world comes and bites you
back bro it's bro you had your chance in
it that's all I'm saying in it did
someone hurt you I feel like this person
classic
it's ruin it no I'm good I'm Gucci trust
me you can tell number one that's always
the number one comment when someone a
man is speaking fast
I completely agree because when I
sometimes you know I used to sometimes
go to Mayfair clubs and then you have
the people with the tables and the
bottles
and it's just it's just like yeah the
sparklers that's what you just said
whatever it's always weirdos anyways and
you just stand there and then it's true
like most girls chase after these guys
but you can just tell by the way these
guys move like if there's 20 girls
they're probably more interested in
getting into gang bang then bad boys as
well you like the bad guys
you've never had a bad boy face I've
I've had it before so that also was yes
can I talk yeah of course you can but I
realized that how old was you when you
realized
like two years ago how many years did
you leave
it was only when I came to London
a year-ish but then I just realized it
wasn't for me because for me personally
what I look for in people and in friends
and stuff is way deeper than this you
know like I had an epiphany I hear that
I don't know I feel like I feel like for
you it's what you said it's like if you
really and truly look inside yourself
you want someone that really values you
these people that chase after multiple
people they're not in this space so if
you choose to are you talking about men
or women both ways because there's also
that's what that's what we like to do we
like to chase after multiple women with
that variety
some girls it's what you say they they
have the choice to be with the good guy
but they want to be with with someone
that it looks looks more attractive I
think I think I think that all girls
want a guy that other women want I don't
think there's a single girl that wants a
guy that nobody wants that's true no
that's true but what I'm saying is if
you if you do the look with if you do
the if you look within yourself yeah and
if you want someone that only wants you
yeah and you chase after people that
want multiple people that are valued by
multiple people then you make that
choice to get hurt because you see the
way they move and you don't tell me tell
your friends
but I've had this convert with many of
my friends where I'm like what did they
say when you say this to them oh they
don't like it but I don't care because I
need to speak the truth right and I'm
saying you're actively making the choice
to interact with these people and you
keep doing it again so you shouldn't so
you shouldn't have sympathy the same way
I don't have sympathy you shouldn't have
a sympathy as well yes we you see what
king Richie was saying here you was like
oh like like who hurt him but you have
to understand something yeah like he's
just representing all the men that he
speaks to no no like it's not right I
thought it's powerful no but it's nobody
you said who hurt you
he's like the reason it's something that
we commonly get when we start speaking
with passion here they're like who hurt
you it's not that what hurt it's just
that we represent I recognize her hey do
I look at her
I love it so so we have to laugh because
it's like okay cool it was supposed to
be a laughable moment okay so what's up
so once we get past that it's like okay
we're not hurt but there's a lot of men
that we represent it's not it's not just
you like like this is just for women
always yeah like it's it's it's you guys
say things but you don't know how many
times you've heard this on the channel
just like you said you're representing a
lot of men and you're not necessarily
hurt yourself yeah I've been sitting
here talking quite passionately about
men being delusional and Men lying and
being manipulative I'm not talking from
a place of her personally yeah I've had
one mess up I'm not even joking like one
mess up where with a guy with an idiot
guy okay and I like my lesson but well I
never said but I never said who hurt you
I know you didn't so I know you did that
but I just wanna I just want to clarify
that because I felt like I was
championing that a lot and I don't want
anyone to like not use I am not the
Egypt girl okay I'm not Deborah with the
same old repetitive guy okay but I know
a lot of women who have been
manipulative and I manipulated and
that's but I empathize with them is what
I'm saying it's literally just because
women are dating the same guy yeah again
it goes back to only only 20 of men
really get to pick another 80 or whoever
whoever will take them so if you choose
to go after your top 20 guy and he
cheats sorry don't really feel bad
listen if you picked he want him to be
over six foot you want him to make money
you want to be attractive you want also
to be obsessed with you it's like we've
been sold a dream it doesn't be fairy
tale [ __ ] that's not real yeah you're
kind of pulling the true symptoms as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible